Looking back at our universe where there's only two positive charges.
I'll call them q1 and q2 and in this case they're both positive, but they can be negative or one of each.
It turns out that the electric potential energy is equal to some constant Kq1q2/r.
Now K is just a constant. Its value is 910⁹
and maybe you can tell me by doing your dimensional analysis skills
what the units are, but that's for the forums.
What this equation tells us is that well if the charge is bigger
either this charge is the potential energy increases proportionally.
If the distance of separation is bigger, the potential energy decreases proportionally.
The derivation for this equation is actually really fascinating, something we won't do here,
but it basically comes from the idea that there's a certain amount of work required
to move these charges from very, very far away into this configuration
and that work happens to be equal to this.
Let's do some quick practice, let's imagine that q1 is actually a minus charge
of -1c and q2 with a +3c, and let's say the separation between them is 2 m.
You need to tell me the potential energy. I've already filled in the x10¹⁰
because that's what your exponent is going to want to be when you convert this to scientific notation.
You can you just fill in this part here with the potential energy ought to be
and be very careful with the sign.